The human body is made up of 78 organs,
206 bones, and trillions of cells. This
enormous number of parts needs to be in
constant contact, despite the huge
distance that separates them. Small
messengers, called hormones, are what
help us communicate a message from one
part of the body to another. Hormones
are involved in many important
biological processes, regulating
reproduction, stress, inflammation and
metabolism. Let's say you just ate a
big meal. As your stomach breaks down
the food, it makes a sugar called
glucose. Glucose will travel from the
stomach to the bloodstream. Eventually,
it makes it to the pancreas, one of the
body's many glands. Glands act like
post offices for the body. These glands
can sense what's happening in the blood,
like all that glucose from your meal.
They then release different hormones as
letters that tell the rest of the body
how to respond. After the glucose makes
it to the pancreas gland, the pancreas
releases a hormone called insulin. This
insulin will go back into the
bloodstream and travel throughout the
whole body, telling your fat cells to
start absorbing more sugar from the
bloodstream to get your glucose levels
back to normal. The post office has to
make sure that the correct hormone
letters get to the correct mailbox, or
cell. For example, insulin tells cells
to absorb sugar from the bloodstream.
But adrenaline, a stress hormone, can
tell the body to get ready to fight.
What happens if something goes wrong
with this delivery process? What if
something happens to the mailbox? For
example, the mailbox might already be
stuffed with letters, so no new insulin
letters can it. That's what happens in
type 2 diabetes. Insulin receptors can
no longer detect insulin, and the body
can't regulate blood sugar anymore. Or
something could go wrong at the post
office. Let's say the letters don't get
properly sorted to be delivered. The
mailbox still works fine, but there are
no letters being sent. This is what
happens in type 1 diabetes. Luckily,
because the mailboxes can still
received insulin, we can get around the
slow down at the post office by
introducing insulin into the
bloodstream. Our body has a variety of
different hormones that tell cells
respond in different ways, but all of
them share the same basic delivery
system. Glands receive a signal to
produce a hormone and then they send
out that hormone to the rest of the
body. It's an effective way to get all
the parts of the body on the same page
to coordinate important functions.